today's speed is going to be a bit
different because we are going to
discuss if we are still in a bear Market
or if we are now in a bull market
and I know that you know this is quite
like a mixed opinion if I made a pool
now
the results are probably going to be 50
50. and that is why I think that this is
an important topic to bring up in the
channel
it's very simple it's a crossover of two
EMAs in the weekly time frame now I know
that you have the death cross the Golden
Cross and whatsoever
um if I'm correct and I'm not wrong I
think the death cruise and the Golden
Cross I think they say that it's the
50ma and the 200ma
this is different because we're talking
about EMAs no Amaze EMA means
exponential moving average and EMA and
Ma are two different formulas okay and
also I'm using the 20 EMA and the 50ma
right I'm going to show you now in the
history of Bitcoin why I think that this
is a good indicator
um why I think that in previous times
it's been a good signal it's important
that you understand that it's a lagging
indicator so you're gonna lose some
appreciation in price you know when the
signal happens but you want to have
confirmation
which is also quite important uh you can
see it's very simple okay you have the
20 EMA which is the yellow line and you
also have that 50 EMA which is the
purple line so it's as simple as this
when the 20ma crosses below the 50ma
that's a bad Market signal okay
um when the yellow line
crosses above
the purple line so basically when the
when the 20ma crosses above the 50ma
like this okay then this is telling you
that it's a bull market
okay and price suit then
go up okay the EMA should push price up
it's as simple as that I'm gonna go now
back to 2014.
okay so that's 90 years ago and we're
gonna go through all these crossovers
so let's go there
um 2014
these are the first crossover that we
have here okay
um you have here the bear Market a
confirmation here you could discuss that
you know the bear Market started here
maybe uh if you're going to the
validation you can see maybe here WB
pattern and of course yes remember that
this is a login indicator okay so when
it prints and that would be
in this one here okay
that's telling you that we're in a bear
Market you can see the price drops from
there
let me check
price drops from there
at 63 okay and then you know he
establishes in in this area
so that's the first thing now we have
here
the next crossover okay the 20ma
crossing above the 50ma that's telling
you that we have a bull market okay
um usually you can see that it's quite
normal the you know you see a big pump
so that gives time the 20ma to cross
above the 50ma and then when price
retest the 20ma that's when you can buy
and that's a device one and this quite
safe to buy that okay and you can see in
this example how much percent up
this is uh 5500 percent of okay that's
that's nuts uh then 2018
again what this one actually came in a
very good timing okay
um you have here again the 20ma crosses
Crossing below the 50ma bear Market sign
um from nearly drops UH 60 percent
you have again
another signal here
okay
bull market
the pumps
150 percent
not bad
and then I know that here gets quite
messy in 2020 with the with the coffee
drop okay this drop was crazy nobody saw
this drop
coming and you can see that it proves
that it's quite like an indicator
because it's signal is twice okay but
then price ends up recovering so this
one is kind of like a Blackstone event
to be honest and it didn't do great here
to be honest okay
so now if we go back here you know you
have the bear Market signal in April
from Daddy drops of to be another sixty
percent so you can kind of notice
I wonder if you've noticed but when we
have the better Market signal it tends
to drop our sixty percent okay it's
happened before so it's possible that
this is the Bitcoin bottom okay now what
is important here remember it's a login
indicator so the most likely thing is
that if we want to see this crossover
here
first and then when we see this pump is
when this cross can happen
all right and then yes of course the
EMAs are going to catch up with price
price can retested this would be a good
buying opportunity okay
um to be honest if you notice we're
buying pretty pretty much at the same
process where now okay
missing much and you know that then
price is gonna should go higher from
there okay so that's what I'm keeping an
eye on now it's very possible
you know if we see a drop now
we end up saying something like this
okay
I'm not going to tell you that we are in
a bull market until I see at least this
signal happening
all right I hope that's very clear now I
know that we have you know the Harvin
coming next year so let's talk about it
okay uh these four blue lines you know
vertical lines they are the time
when we had the Halloween's okay so
let's see how price
reacted to this albums okay you can see
here in 2012 November the Halloween
happened and we took
uh 50 days so you know that's almost two
months one month and a half-ish until we
saw price going up okay so that's almost
two months you can see that then you
know half in two months price goes up
we had here another halbin
this is in 2016 in the 11th of July
uh from here it's interesting because
price drops first okay uh but you can
see that if we check
prices can go higher
until let me check how long this is
105 days that's around three months okay
so price takes three months three months
and a half
to go up okay so you can see that when
the Halloween happens
you have to be very careful because what
happened here is probably quite scary
okay we saw a drop right after right
after the Halloween of a thirty percent
okay then it took three months until we
saw price going up okay so it's
important because when you see the
halving you shouldn't expect price to go
up immediately
2020 this was the last album again
um 11th of May ish do you know that week
and price took
70 days so that's uh two months or two
months and 10 days
two months and a half you can say two
months two months and a half until price
went High okay
so what can we say about this we can see
that usually right after the Halloween
price
takes between two and three months to go
up and the next Halloween is in April
well they still don't we still don't
know the date but
um it's very likely that it's between
March
April and May of 2024 okay I've marked
in my chart April but the point is that
you have to understand that once we see
the halving okay price is gonna take
between two and three months okay
to do something like this okay uh so if
that's April I would say then until the
end of July so July I know versus when
you see price going higher and that's
why everybody is expecting because you
know if you go against the halby now
against the 40-year cycle
and you tell me that we are going to see
this
okay
then your centimeter this time is going
to be different
and there is not really much
justification of that okay that would be
to see a big bull market
from
summer of next year
okay of course I'm gonna keep you
updated until then I'm not going
anywhere bro
this is what we can expect based on the
previous halvins and the 4gr Cycles okay
that we see a big Trend to the upside
from
end of July
and August I would probably August I
would say okay you have to be safe so
that's that's when you want to be in the
game okay I think I want to have a very
if this plays out we're gonna have a
very good time in crypto so that is
pretty much everything I will tell you I
cannot confirm to you so if you ask me
are we in a bull market I'm gonna reply
no we are in a bear Market until it's
invalid okay and it's invalid when we
see this crossover of the 20 and the
50ma okay that's what I'm gonna tell you
that's the first thing that I need to
see
in order to say that we are no longer in
a bear Market I hope that's clear
and still you know we could even see
something similar to what we saw during
the Kobe dump but to the upside we would
say like a fake pump okay so
um it still it wouldn't convince but it
would tell me that yeah that's a good
that's a good indicator okay that's a
good signal uh now we might see
something similar to what we saw in 2019
okay uh the Halloween was in May 2020
and exactly one year before the halbin
we saw the bullish Crush
okay that's also in May then price
pumped you know with the crossover and
then consolidate uh this is the well
they call it dump
okay
and then we had the Harbin press took to
two and a half months to pump and then
we saw this epic bull market that we had
so if you notice now the next albinism
is in April well in Spring of 2024
where is actually one year before it
happens and we might be seeing something
very similar okay women be seen the
bullish cross if we see a pump here okay
then this one is cross would print
and then you know who could go higher
just to consolidate again who knows when
we see again price dropping
okay stabilize
now we have the Halloween with two and a
half months or so so that will be until
logos and this is when we would say
price going up
okay
so why not women might see something
like this okay now to be honest this
Corbett dump is quite scary imagine
for something like this to happen again
okay that we almost released the lows so
if we say something similar
that would go all the way down maybe all
the way to this liquidity pool over here
to 17K okay but to see something like
this obviously you wanna need
some really bad news let me remove all
these drawings
uh because I want to show you something
interesting okay and you're gonna see
throw away I've been telling you for
quite some time about this Zone here
okay so that's uh 25
250 ish okay now when I see it one now
uh I'll do it white okay and if you
notice here okay it's it's a it's a Zone
where we saw
a sell-off okay another sell-off and we
haven't tested a support yet so it was a
big resistance that in theory we should
test a support and that's right below
the 50 and the 20 EMAs in the weekly
time frame so imagine for a second if
this happens okay we come down to test
these previous resistance as support
okay so we go below this 2 am EMAs all
right and we fail
to test this resistance support okay and
we go down okay what would happen then
then we could expect these two EMAs to
turn around okay invalid the bullish
cross
and you would see price going down and I
mean
in the chart we have a couple of excuses
to visit these zones okay we have a
liquidity pool
over here
there goes
all the way to 22k we also have
this
week over here okay that goes all the
way to 20K well 19 and a half
so I'm telling you these excuses for
this to happen this is what I'm telling
you if I say right now oh it looks that
we are forming a bullish crossover it's
looking good I mean yes but it's a half
truth because the bullish crucial what
hasn't happened yet okay so this is
still a chance that maybe next week or
the week after you see a dump okay and
that's when I make the 20ma
and the 50ma to turn around again in
case you don't want to continue in this
downtrend you're gonna have a bullish
Crush and then the 20 and the 50 Amaze
they're gonna push price low okay maybe
to this liquidity pool maybe to this
week maybe to this all the liquidity
pool so I'm telling you there are
reasons to go down again to be honest
the marker is not looking great neither
they want to have a recession so let's
see how price reacts to the what I don't
want is to see another you know Falls uh
Buddhist crossover okay and then that we
see something like this again another
baby screws over and that's what
happened here
in the kobit dump if you notice here
price domes Costa cobit you have the
baddest crossover then price recovers
and instead of testing the 20 and the 15
is resistance okay that doesn't happen
prices goes up so you have another
bullish crossover here and at the end of
the day this is just noise because if
you notice here
price is at the same level
two months later okay
um you know what matters is that you had
the bullish cruise over here
right this is just noise you are here
some kind of deviation
okay they fill this liquidity pool for
example over here if you notice almost
to the dollar very accurate and then
just continues going up so that's the
thing that you don't want to see here
again okay you don't want to see
something like this what you would like
to see is first you would need to see a
pump
okay then when you see a pump Above This
highs that is when you are gonna be able
to see this bullish crossover and then
ideally what you'd like to see is price
coming back down
and test the 20maas support
and then you can see continuation to the
upside and even if you lose the 20ma you
still have the 50ma
but that's literally the last thing that
you are holding to okay because if you
lose this one then yes price is gonna go
low again and you're gonna have another
batteries crossover so ideally what I
would like to say is
we will need to see a pump
okay
Buddhist crossover
let me draw it better Buddhist crossover
then you need price to come back down to
the 20ma test their support and then you
can go higher so that's what we want to
see
okay if in the other hand we see a dump
you're going to see the EMAs tearing
around again and then yes we're gonna go
to the liquidity pool to this week to
this other liquidity pool I'm trying to
be as neutral as possible and I'm you
know basing this analysis so on this
indicator Based on data that has
happened before also based on the Harbin
okay we have a Harbin in AP in Wellness
spring 2024 so here according to the
four-year cycle that the moment is
intact you know it's been working well
so far so if we place out the same again
from here if you wait two months Okay so
that would be
I I would say between July and August
end of July start of August
from here to see price going up again
okay
that's what we're expecting then what
happens in between in this one here who
knows what happens that's why I'm
keeping an eye on the crossover because
you see the crossover okay you have
reasons to believe that maybe price can
go all the way to the Zone again okay
then maybe you see some kind of retrace
and at the end maybe you are still in
this Zone
so this is what I mean guys if you ask
me are we still in a better Market or
are we in a bull market now my answer is
going to be what is still in a better
Market until proven otherwise
okay even if we've double price from the
lows all right because yes we've done a
hundred percent pump you can see that
all right but even so you know you still
don't have any confirmation telling you
that we're gonna go to 40K next
all right the only confirmation to me
would be we have the bullish crossover
and the weekly time frame of the 20 and
the 50ma
and then we tested the 20ma as support
okay in that moment yes I'll be favoring
40K until then we still have the chance
that the bullish crossover gets
invalidated and we see a dump maybe to
22k maybe to 20K right and then this
crossover would be invalidated and we
would still be you know very clearly in
a bear Market
so that's what I want you to keep in
mind
um now based on the four year cycle
I'm gonna be honest with you
you know we've seen that it's been
playing out very well and there is some
kind of pattern that after the Halloween
we have between two and three months of
you know
some kind of sideways okay uh so that's
what I'm expecting for the next bull
market I don't know if you're gonna see
again the crossover and a pump or if
we're gonna see a dump and then you know
the crossover gets invalidated but what
I can tell you is that I think that it's
very likely that by August of 2020 for
July and August
what gonna be in a very good uh uptrend
or that's you know that's what time and
data and history has been telling us
since then all right you can see here
why not why couldn't we expect
another big uptrend from August 2024.
all right not supporting that theory
he's saying that this time is going to
be different right uh so that's what I'm
gonna keep an eye on okay August 2024 we
should see a big bull market uh until
then who knows we might see this is an
area playing out that I drew here or we
could see uh the the other scenario that
it's basically invalidating the bullish
cross price goes down you know and we
can you know we're establishing this
Zone over here
um so that's what I think guys I hope
that the video is clear thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon